[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce que vous ne feriez pas pour
vos enfants
j'étais cadre médico-social
postale responsabilité
good job bonne paye
ordinateur stylo
tout ce qu'il faut
et pourtant j'ai tout laissé tomber
pour aller sous la pluie
dans la chaleur
dans la mangrove dans mon anneau en
compagnie des crabes et des moustiques
avec mes bottes qui restent pris dans la
boue en train de touiller la terre
cette décision je l'ai prise à bon
escient et je l'assume
ma fille était allergique à de multiples
aliments destructeurs
et c'est tout à fait normalement que
j'ai pris la décision
d'embrasser une carrière d'un groupe
biologiste
agriculteur
franchement je ne savais pas que la
société guadeloupéenne
ne regardez pas ces producteurs comme
des porteurs d'avenir
c'est vrai quand je suis allé
m'installer
on m'a tout simplement rayonné on me
disant vous allez faire de l'agriculture
biologique comment vous allez rejoindre
les Bolos
je me suis pas laissé démonter
mais c'était sans contrer la
maltraitance institutionnelle quand j'ai
voulu m'installer parce que franchement
être agriculteur
vous avez votre notification positive
et quelques fois il vous faut attendre
un an deux ans voire trois ans pour
avoir les fonds qui vous sont attribués
il y a trois ans avant on a le temps de
crever en fait
et malgré tout ça
j'ai pas lâché
en plus il y avait quand je suis arrivé
cette histoire de chlordécone
comme qui a fait beaucoup de
Guadeloupéens se détourner de la
production locale
et puis bon
les banques
les banques en croix de l'eau
franchement pour la financement agricole
il préfère financer une voiture plutôt
qu'à des outils pour faire des légumes
mais bon je me suis pas démonté pour
autant
doucement calmement
avec maman
mon mari
ma fille on a commencé à livrer
des petites mamans comme moi qui avait
des enfants allergiques
et puis je me faisant
j'ai rencontré le groupement des
agriculteurs bio avec qui là on a
structuré un système de panier au top
avec
on s'est un petit peu inspiré de la map
la map que vous connaissez peut-être
association pour le développement
de l'agriculture paysanne
mais là là
moi je lis
je l'ai mis à ma sauce
parce que dans un premier temps
tous les clients militants qui venaient
chez nous prendre leur contrats et leurs
abonnements de livraison de paniers
chaque semaine nous permettait d'avoir
un petit matelas financier
ce qui nous a permis en fait
grâce à cette stabilité
on a pu petit à petit fixer les
le paiement des collègues
non pas en fonction du marché mais en
fonction du coût de production et là ça
change tout pourquoi ça change tout
grâce à ça on a pu aider les
agriculteurs conventionnelles qui
souhaitaient cheminer vers le bureau
peut-être quand vous ne savez pas mais
quand un collègue conventionnel chimique
veut passer vers le bio il a une période
de conversion
donnant deux ans trois ans et c'est une
phase très difficile et beaucoup
abandonne donc grâce aux clients
militants nous avons pu nous à notre
échelle
payer les collègues au même prix que ce
qui est intelligent bio
ça nous a fait une petite équité entre
agriculture
mais pour faire ça
pour faire ça on a dû
s'armer
dans logiciel de gestion des paniers que
nous avons créé nous-même de A à Z en
Guadeloupe c'est la seule qui existe en
Guadeloupe
et ce logiciel
il nous a permis d'aller jusqu'au bout
de faire une super trace habilité pour
les clients c'est la meilleure des
Antilles
mais
cela ne s'arrête pas là puisque grâce à
cette traçabilité un client militant il
sait par exemple le 7 mars qu'il a eu un
kilo de concombre de telles producteurs
la commune et surtout si la producteur
et en bio ou en Converse sur
et c'est fort du respect qu'on a pour
ses clients militants qui quand même
chaque semaine se déplace
prennent leur panier ils ne savent pas
en avance ce qui a dans le pari c'est
important c'est important parce que là
le client n'est plus waouh
c'est le légume qui commence
et quand la légume commence
quelquefois quand il s'agit d'un légume
de sauvegarde ou de légumes ouvriers
oubliés le client militant ça demande
what qu'est-ce que je vais bien pouvoir
faire avec ça
ah ben c'est le cas de certains légumes
comme le pitchenga quand vous connaissez
peut-être
on l'appelle courgette créole
et justement ça tombe bien c'est une
cucurbitation qui
supporte la pluie et qui résiste pendant
la période de l'hivernage donc en fait
quand les courgettes standard n'arrive
plus à nager après Fiona
lui fait sa natation
[Applaudissements]
il en va de même
pour nos petites pour une café
alors c'est vrai que on Guadeloupe on
n'avait pas le droit de planter du
raisin malgré sous nos terroir on peut
faire deux réponses
merci pas grave l'interdiction
et puis on va produire nos propres
raisins les points café
ça c'est de chez nous super résistant
pas du tout fragile et donc
ça je vous conseille
de bien les malaxer
avant d'aller consommer pour pouvoir
extraire tout le sucre
les clients militants
ils nous aide à sauvegarder ce genre de
variété de légumes
mon chapeau mais pendant les périodes
critiques dans nos crises
on a pu constater que grâce
à la régularité des clients
nous on a pu exister pour pouvoir donner
à la population
de quoi se nourrir quand le bateau ne
rentrait pas
[Applaudissements]
mais mais quand les clients militants on
fait tout ça ils ont dû rester parce
qu'une fois quand les vannes étaient
ouvertes et que le bateau revenait il y
avait plus de clients
sauf les militants de base donc les
clients militants ils servent aussi à
maintenir un système qui va peut-être
aider en cas de crise
cela dit je vous le dis
même si
nous nous avons nos habitudes de rire
c'est notre plat national il faut quand
même penser aux équivalents
les poids de bois ou autre c'est ça qui
va nous sauver en cas de de résilience
et je tiens encore au chapeau pour ses
clients militants qui font ce travail et
non
et je vous assure que bientôt
nous en Guadeloupe nous ne serons plus
spectateurs
dans notre consommation mais acteur et
là on ne parlera plus de boulot
pour les agriculteurs biologiques mais
nous y sommes déjà
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]